[Música]
la guerra civil de el salvador se
prolongó durante más de una década el
conflicto empezó el 10 de enero de 1981
cuando el recién formado frente
farabundo martí para la liberación
nacional anunció su ofensiva general y
se prolongó oficialmente hasta el 16 de
enero de 1992 con los llamados acuerdos
de chapultepec firmados en la ciudad de
mexico pero que se celebraron en todo el
salvador en cuya capital una multitud se
congregó frente al palacio nacional la
guerra civil salvadoreña tuvo una serie
de graves violaciones de derechos
humanos entre estos miles de niños
fueron víctimas de la trata organizada
se estima que alrededor de 30.000 fueron
enviados al extranjero para su adopción
a menudo sin el consentimiento de sus
padres este pasado turbios intentó
enterrar que nada de la amnistía pero
que ha sido de esos niños enviados al
extranjero durante este conflicto
esto es boleto de vuelta a el salvador
[Música]
es un boleto de vuelta a la tierra que
dejó hace 35 años
este es el país donde podría haber
estado donde podría haber vivido es el
que pongo cuando la gente me pregunta mi
lugar de nacimiento el salvador medio
nació así en medio de la guerra civil a
las pocas semanas fue enviado a francia
donde sus padres adoptivos lo espera
ahora buenos días ahora es a su madre
biológica quien quiere encontrar empleo
muchas gracias yo comenzó la búsqueda
hace un año y medio a través de pro
búsqueda una asociación que trata de
encontrar a los 3.000 o más niños que
desaparecieron durante el conflicto su
madre ha sido identificada gracias a los
archivos luego de una prueba de adn está
viva
solo falta organizar el encuentro
probablemente tendrá un momento para que
ella le cuente lo que pasó
sería un momento muy importante
bien cuento contigo para la traducción
es ponerle palabras y cara a una
historia que no conocía pero que es
sospechado durante 35 años así que es
normal que provoque ansiedad
eduardo solía volver a tejer historias
desgarradoras por la guerra la
asociación ha reunido a casi 500
familias la mayoría de los casos que
tienen provocada la iniciativa desde los
padres a buscar verdad somos una
organización que buscamos a niños y
niñas que fueron desaparecidos
forzadamente durante el conflicto armado
verdad y muchos de ellos fueron dados en
adopción en otros países y algunos
regalados internamente y apropiados por
militares o por otros familiares un
abogado podría cobrar entre 2.000 y
15.000 dólares por adopción el mercado
para los niños salvadoreños era jugoso
pero lleno de papeles y alias falsos
muchos fueron presentados como huérfanos
cuando se les quitaron a sus padres
[Música]
matthew se sumergirá primero en el país
durante unos días en medio de la
pandemia de kobe 19 los salvadoreños
mantienen la fiesta como todos los que
han conocido la guerra veo a esta gente
y creo que ese podría haber sido mi
lugar también
[Música]
rufina no ha tenido mucho ambiente de
fiesta de joven primero uso de las
palizas de su madre y luego de las de su
violento marido
trabajaba como empleada doméstica en una
casa de familia para la que su embarazo
era un inconveniente de resolver cuando
yo estaba embarazada tenía como seis
meses aún menos cuando o siete meses
cuando ips la cnea mili eva me dijo hay
que dar el niño en adopción me dice no
no no va a andar rodando con el niño así
me dijo el mundial no tener a dónde ir
el final acepta y luego se arrepiente no
es demasiado tarde matthew aún no había
nacido pero su destino ya aparecía
decidido este no te puedes echar para
atrás me dijo
porque acordate me dijo que que carlos
he abogado me diría esta pieza puedes ir
medio
apenas 24 horas después de nacer ac fue
llevado por una abogada a la que rufina
no volvió a ver en 35 años
como creo que voy a mentir y yo no me
quería morir sin conocer a este niño
y al mínimo el más chiquito
a pesar de su ausencia más yo mantuvo su
lugar en los recuerdos de rufina ella
los amo jimmy dice el mes de enero me
llama la atención porque mis tres hijos
son de este mes el primero se llama
giovanni y nació a las 11 45 de la
mañana el día 28 de enero de 1981 en el
hospital de maternidad y el otro
se llama jimmy y nació del día
10 de enero cuando más fi nació en 1985
el mercado salvadoreño de niños ya
estaba funcionando el país se había
sumido en el caos el destino de los
huérfanos de guerra causó emoción y
explotaron las solicitudes de adopción
así que los casos se resolvieron
rápidamente y sin tradición
un pequeño grupo de abogados concentró
la mayoría de los procedimientos
ninguno de ellos se ha preocupado nunca
por el sistema de justicia
a pesar de los numerosos casos probados
de pacificación de documentos entre
ellos alicia zelaya ahora profesora de
la universidad de san salvador- no
respondió a nuestras solicitudes de
entrevista
el día que tanto espera rufina ha
llegado ajustes finales para una casa
modesta pero impecable pamela la
psicóloga de pro búsqueda le ayuda a
mantener los pies en la tierra como le
decía verdad
tanto como puede haber resultado que
sigan en comunicación existe una
posibilidad que no espero o sea que de
repente él
[Música]
ha esperado 35 años pero los últimos
minutos parecen una eternidad
buenos días
no
y
bajo mi amor
[Música]
es idéntico a mi hermano y mi niño más
allá de esta reunión también es un álbum
familiar entero que está siendo
reconstruido
por mi mamá mi papá y mi mamá vacío
conoce a su medio hermano jesús después
de dar rienda suelta a los sentimientos
vienen las palabras y las caras se
relaja si hay algo que como que aún no
se entregó
y ya dice uno más ya ya pasó todo ya yo
me siento más tranquila
ya me puedo morir algo yo le agradezco
también a los señores que lo crearon
por qué
después de que no era su hijo y los
quieren igual que es como si fueran sus
propios hijos
rufina y matthew han hecho las paces con
su pasado pero las montañas en áreas
remotas todavía contienen enigmas
dolorosos
el caso son de dos niños
que no tenemos la certeza si fueron
trasladados por la fuerza armada después
de ejecutar a su día a su abuela a su
mamá porque si hay testimonios
contundentes que al menos 20 niños en
ese operativo de esta zona fueron ser
fueron sacado hacia los cuarteles
eduardo tiene un valioso aliado en el
campo este detector localiza objetos
metálicos y lo más importante detecta
objetos huecos como cráneos la región de
chalatenango ha sido escenario de
atrocidades que seguimos descubriendo si
los insurgentes marxistas también
cometieron abusos el ejército sería
responsable del 85 por ciento de los
muertos y desaparecidos oficialmente
sólo atacaban los campamentos de la
guerrilla y los útiles de la cocina esto
evidencia que la población civil la que
se encontraba en este lugar
este es el lote donde vivía la familia
donde fueron asesinados posiblemente los
dos niños y cuatro adultos verdad
no queda nada de la aldea
el ejercito arrasaba con todo gracias a
una larga encuesta pro búsqueda ha
identificado las ruinas de 36 casas
esperanza se acababa de ir cuando los
soldados llegaron ese día
y yo me quería regresar
una gente conocida y me dieron no
esperanza no regresó
con tiene medios para adelante no para
atrás medio porque si ellas tienen de
librarse tierra para librar yo sino que
decía la voluntad de dios
desde ese día ha estado buscando a sus
sobrinos uno tenía tres años y el otro
cuarenta días
y contaron que le dieron muerte a ella
me dijeron que los niños no los han
hallado aquí sólo hay algunos pañales
encima y desechos en el circuito que
están
pensamiento
el detector pronto da señales muy claras
a otro cráneo ya no hay duda los cráneos
de los cuatro adultos yacen bajo sus
pies
la alegría no solo encontrarlo ya sea
vivo ya muerto sino el saber dónde están
el poderlos visitar pero poderlos tener
el poder dignificar esta sepultura de
eso se tratan pero no hay rastro de los
niños los pequeños cuerpos pueden no
haber resistido a la prueba del tiempo
pro búsqueda no puede llevar a cabo las
excavaciones esto tendrá que ser hecho
por los servicios del estado
esta vez pequeñitas 12%
pudiera ser un niño
fueron enterrados devorados por los
animales llevados por los militares y
luego los dados en adopción hoy
esperanza tiene al menos un consuelo el
consuelo de finalmente poder ponerle
flores a la tumba de su familia tuvo
juicios por crímenes de guerra después
de los acuerdos de paz
los archivos del ejército nunca se
abrieron así que secciones enteras de la
historia siguen enterradas que pasó en
el mozote el 12 de diciembre de 1981
casi 1000 civiles fueron asesinados por
soldados del batallón atlacatl el único
sobreviviente murió en 2005
se trata de la mayor masacre de la
historia reciente de américa latina que
se conmemora hoy hay organizaciones
sociales embajadores un representante de
la onu pero ningún miembro del gobierno
salvadoreño está presente en la asamblea
ignacio se encuentra con reina la
coordinadora de pro búsqueda del pueblo
mártir lo que querían era tener a toda
la gente aquí hombres mujeres con niños
familias completas verdad tenerlas aquí
y ya después en vos tres veces para allá
vos te vas para casa y decidieron a las
niñas de 13 14 15 años las pusieron a un
lado las mujeres más mayores a otro lado
los hombres para otro lado sacaban así
los grupos de los diferentes lugares a
matarlos y se escuchaban aquellos gritos
lamentos de la gente cuando la estaban
matando en este pueblo convento situado
frente a ellos se encontraron los
cuerpos de 140 niños
no esperaba que fuera una exploración
tan dolorosa el hecho de que todavía
haya debates es algo que me sorprende
descubrir pueden ver que muchas cosas no
se dicen muchas cosas se ocultan y
todavía hay muchos tabúes entre los
nuevos dirigentes
reina perdió la pista de sus dos
sobrinas de 7 y 14 años sus cuerpos
nunca fueron encontrados y se rumora que
unos 20 niños fueron capturados vivos
por los soldados ese día pero todo esto
solo se sabrá si los actores del
conflicto colaboran
mauricio vargas es un ex general de las
fuerzas armadas ahora miembro del
parlamento defiende el secreto de los
archivos militares y el honor de la
institución es que los militares no eran
los responsables de eso
yo fui comandante de unidades de combate
los militares no se ayudaron niños de
zonas de combate
y estoy diciendo no es la
responsabilidad
de el componente militar los militares
que lo pudiesen haber hecho tienen una
responsabilidad personal pero no una
concepción institucional que se fuera la
norma que se debería de seguir no el
trabajo que la justicia no hace queda a
cargo de la sociedad civil
[Música]
gracias a pro búsqueda más yo descubrió
un pequeño país con inmensos paisajes y
profundas cicatrices y encontró una
madre
[Música]
y siempre ha tenido su lugar desde el
principio es la persona con la que pasé
nueve meses antes de nacer ya tenía su
lugar y ese lugar nunca se perderá nunca
la olvidaré solo que el destino fue otro
hace 35 años y ahora tengo una familia
en francia una vida de francia
pamela sabe que las reuniones entre
familias separadas pueden ser el
principio de una historia o el final de
un ciclo y no hay ninguna historia
definida de antemano hay algunos casos
en los que los jóvenes que han sido
adoptados en el extranjero continúan
comunicándose con su familia salvadoreña
pero en otros casos vienen al salvador o
se comunican virtualmente con ellos para
el encuentro eso es todo lo que querían
hacer tenían preguntas tenían curiosidad
por saber pero no más que eso
como verde
de matanzas tropical
cuando eduardo y toda la familia
separada del conflicto seguirá luchando
por desenterrar testimonios e
investigaciones la verdad es que aún
pueden alcanzar para que toda una
generación de padres madres tíos díaz
hermanos o hermanas de las víctimas
puedan despedirse poco a poco con un
corazón seria
[Aplausos]
bueno
hasta aquí boleto de vuelta el salvador
sí de saber nuevamente este reportaje lo
invitamos a visitar france24 puntocom
[Música]